hi my name is dr. Kyle Keene I am going
to talk about how we use Wolfram
language inside of MIT s undergraduate
curriculum in multiple departments
for those of you who were here last 30
minutes I am still Kyle keen for for
those of you who are new i am kyle key
still yeah I teach and do lots of stuff
at MIT and I am an absolute Wolfram
lover I guess I would just college so
yes the things I'm going to talk about
are just what we have been doing at MIT
to bring know my scroll baller doesn't
show up all right what I've been doing
at MIT to try to bring coding and
computational thinking into the
curriculum I have this really great
position where I can get hired by other
departments to teach classes so I'm not
really stuck in my department so I've
worked with physics and computer science
and material science and I have some
grants out to hopefully break into the
humanities so I I get to kind of be this
all over the place person which suits my
personality well so we'll talk about the
you know I I have a PhD in physics I
learned coding I opened my first
computer my sophomore year in college
and Mathematica was on it and I learned
coding inside of physics so this is like
the heart and soul of what drives me so
I love that I get to be part of the MIT
intro physics class and then my home
department right now is material science
and engineering and what they hired me
for was to bring coding throughout their
curriculum as well as have a designated
class about computational methods that
I'm helping professor Craig Carter who
most of you not most of you some of you
may know he's a long-term Wolfram user
and yeah and then the online physics
course I'll talk a bit more about the
content that we actually throw into
these online courses and the experiment
that we're running to understand if it's
actually valuable to put widgets or
coding or if we should just let students
do paper and pencil math which I don't
personally believe but I would love to
see data to support so we will begin
with
my head of there there's a few things
that I believe when teaching with
computational methods inside of classes
you can scaffold students up and then
fade how much support you're giving them
so students have some concept of
material science they understand
diffusion as a random walk on a lattice
so if you walk around on a lattice at
some point you end up some distance away
from where you start it and you can plot
if you do that a bunch of different
times what the expected position the
distance away from the center is and so
you can show students how to do that in
one dimension and the code is very
simple it's really kind of approachable
and you just have them stepping back and
forth on a number line and at some point
the integer ends up different than it
started and you look at the distance by
subtracting and you can get a nice plot
so by almost completing this entire
thing you've pretty much modeled how to
solve the problem and my favorite thing
in Wolfram is how simple it is to move 1
D 2 to D 2 nd as soon as you do to D
you're just kind of off and running and
you can just do however many dimensions
you want so by the time you show them
two dimensions you say here here's a
vector here's how you describe two
points on a lattice they can pretty much
fill in all of these gaps by moving
across and then by the end they should
essentially be able to generalize to
three dimensions without you having
provided any specific information so
this is in general my personal belief is
how you blend computation in this is
scaffolded full fade it the scaffolding
is you have to give them something that
they understand that they can build off
of the fading is you start to give them
less and less explicit hand-holding and
the worked example is the fact that they
actually get to see a real-world problem
solved you're not just giving them some
contrived example
okay so the 801 is our intro to physics
it's kinematics you like throw a ball
and see how it flies through the air and
I will just be hopping back and forth
between notebooks to show you wait that
is the other car I'm sorry
not car in a turn I Oh actually it is oh
I get to show you two cars on a Bing
cool so this is what I said is code seal
2.0 so I have a whole authoring system
for creating notebooks that have hidden
content from students that have some
level of Auto grading that have some
level of forced scaffolding and
progressive like you can't move on to
this section until you've done that
section after a lot of user testing last
year I've come back to a much simpler
version of that so there's reading which
is just a notebook
with some contents the problem itself
and now we're looking more like a
traditional textbook where there's some
reading and then there's a problem
injected in the middle but the problem
is a four step process where they need
to read sorry for the scrolling it's a
little bit jumpy read through the
problem try to solve it themselves so
this stage just got unlocked when I read
through the problem and this stage down
here is locked so I can't see the
solution or take a brain break this was
the very first assignment so we just
gave them some silly code so first they
need to come and try some code
themselves we give them some little
indication of of everything that's
inside of these little lightbulb cells
are the things that will actually be
graded so there is a lot of confusion in
the last version
where they didn't know what was being
great at students are disturbingly used
to typing an answer into a box and not
used to sharing a whole narrative and so
we are now giving them a box and I'm
gonna slowly try to get them back out
into feeling like expressive creatures
that can share their thoughts but that's
this is my moment to be on a soapbox I'm
sorry all right so once they lock in
that solution it saves it in the file
they can't edit it anymore
it saves a little hash of it so if they
do try to cheat we can find out
it hasn't been an issue and once they do
that then this stage has become unlocked
where they can see normally this would
be a prototypical solution from the
instructor because in this one we
already gave them everything they need
it they gave them something that might
entertain them hopefully which is a
picture of a cat so normally I would
show them some more detail of how to
solve the problem but in this one we had
already solved that they just needed to
take the code and apply it for
themselves and then important to me is
that they then when they submitted their
answer and then viewed the solution they
get another copy of their solution down
here where they should make edits so
either from taking a break or from
seeing new content that the teacher has
given them I hope that they have some
level of reflection and go back and edit
their work so this is the iterative
process that I try to enforce through
these notebooks which is get a problem
try it yourself see a solution right
then in there see if you can incorporate
any of those changes into your own
solution and I don't know I think it has
been fairly fairly successful so far
oh yeah no actually I'm going to skip on
that one I this this is oh no click the
wrong button
I'm looking forward to presenter tools
being keyboard driven so this is you've
all seen widgets and I didn't want to
show you another widget because you'll
just see infinite widgets at this
conference so in 802 and the electricity
and magnetism we have things like wires
wrapped around electric fields and
showing magnetic fields that emerge as
you move a piece of a magnet through a
wire and showing the currents and all
these little witchetty things that
you've seen so I won't use too much time
about that instead I will get on my
soapbox about computational essays so I
mentioned students typing things in
boxes and how this bothers me because I
feel like we need not just students who
can type things in boxes but ones who
can express themselves so in the
material science course that I teach we
are forcing students to provide whole
narratives so code text images
everything needs to come together in
some coherent way we don't want students
to just think that because they found
you know a number that they actually
solved and understood the problem so the
way that we are accomplishing that is
having students turn in things like this
we ask them what is the partition
function and they need to provide text
explanation math some code some type of
explanation of what the code is doing
and why they feel that it's validly
representing what the partition function
is and this to me is what an actual
student submission should look like
I will admit fully that I spend hours
and hours grading these so if you're
looking for automated grading this is
not the way to go because you can't
grade something this complex but I'm
okay with that because this allows them
to actually represent and express all of
these different things scientific
reasoning computational thinking and
until you give them a place where they
can in
to create all of these skills they're
going to be separate disparate things so
this is I'm a huge fan of the whole
computational essay movement that's my
soapbox about that so I feel like this
little button is skipping things but
maybe it's no it is it's totally
skipping things oh did I click the
furthest one oh my gosh all right
I'm skipping things all right so right
so the next thing I will share is inside
of our inside of our material science
course we do something like a flipped
classroom so we have students who have
they show up to class and they work in
teams of two or three and they work
through teamwork projects I'm a huge fan
of collaborative learning I think that
that's a really important thing that we
need to allow students to have chances
to do which is work with others and so
inside of my notebook I give them some
coding resources some Wikipedia
resources online courses that have stuff
and then I specifically our poor poor
purpose in the class is to take math and
show them where this math is going to
show up in the rest of their curriculum
so I align activities with their future
classes and say okay in three oh one two
you're going to be talking about in 301
two is about thermodynamics and
structure of materials you're going to
be talking about entropy and so I'm
going to give them some amount of
information about entropy let them
visualize it show them how to compute it
they're doing some nice infinite
precision stuff they can find
derivatives of entropy they can find
limits
they can do plots of discretized ideal
entropy which is kind of a normalized
thing and so now I'm showing them inside
of the actual notebook like you learned
about entropy here's how you actually
compute it inside of a Mathematica
environment and then they're scattered
throughout the whole notebook these
little things so if there's this
tendency when you're teaching coding
students will get with their laptop and
they'll just stay there and so if you
have a notebook and you tell them
explicitly go through and when you get
to one of these points you have to stop
talk to your teammate bring over a TA so
this is the way that I enforce them to
actually stay on a collaborative
learning path and you tell them you know
reflect on this thing talk to your
partner about this pull over a TA and
explain to them what this code is doing
and this is the way that we run the
class I I find it much more enjoyable
and engaging and the students seem to
really enjoy it as well so yeah that's
how we use kind of notebooks as tools
for collaborative learning inside of a
classroom so notebooks are very
versatile things and that's that's for
sophomores who have never code it in
material science as well so this is not
an advanced coding classes is for people
who have never code it but there's also
people in the class who are quite
advanced coders and in this
collaborative way you still get the
benefits of peer instruction and
students who are already experts can
teach the ones who don't know and that
reinforces learning for both of them so
there's even if you have a highly
differentiated classroom
this type of Co instruction makes that
very manageable when otherwise if you
stand up at at the front of the board
and lecture at people who understand you
know really deep coding things about
really simple ones then you're going to
lose this group or lose that group so
this this co instruction is my solution
to a highly differentiated classroom the
other thing that we do is in that same
class we force students to take on
take on individual projects so their
homework is you've worked with a
classmate and you've learned how to code
some stuff together now you need to go
and follow this prescribed thing and try
to solve this challenge so in this one
we are trying to convince them that the
curvature of an object's if you take a
bubble and you push it you squeeze it
the curvature increases the surface
energy which makes the thing want to go
back to being a sphere so we need them
to figure out computationally what
curvature is how surface energy is
computed from it and how these things
relate to each other so we use a
notebook we again give them the science
like here's Wikipedia here's some
textbooks and then I'd give them a six
step thing and I say here's your very
open-ended challenge is visualize a
surface visualize a surface with
different curvature find a relationship
between curvature and surface energy use
that relationship to plot and visualize
surface energy so they it's very
open-ended but very clear instructions
and I give them a simple as I said in
the scaffolding I give them a really
simple one-dimensional case so they can
walk through and figure out how I would
do this thing if I was walking and if I
was working in one dimension so I
generate some random data and I use my
little thing to visualize a
one-dimensional solid and then I do
something like an interpolating function
to find the curvature of that solid and
then I do something like a derivative or
second derivative to find the actual
numerical value of the curvature of that
function and then I allow them to move
into two dimensions or three dimensions
or to improve the science so I give them
a really silly curvature surface energy
relationship and one thing that they can
do is go and prove the science behind it
or the other thing is they can
generalize multiple dimensions
so that's notebooks as individual guide
it's assignments where they're doing
that scaffolded learning process the
other thing we do is in the
at projects so this was one student who
became quite interested in microfluidics
so we have a template notebook for
independent projects and we tell them
you have to come up with a research
statement you need to give us some
resources and inspiration so they write
some stuff about their classes they look
inside of textbooks and take pictures of
things inside of textbooks that they
want to visualize they find things on
the demonstrations projects so that they
can have some code inspiration and this
is also these are students doing this I
tell them you first need to give me some
visuals to define what it is you want to
do in a research statement and then they
can actually start to id8 their process
so they you know inside of notebooks you
can easily take pictures and just plop
the picture in there so they have a
fully integrated research environment
where they're learning how to tackle
problems that they find interesting and
so this student did a great job let's
see
oh yeah right so I tell them to create a
sandbox and don't delete anything
because I grade them on the work that
they do even if they don't accomplish
their hopeful final outcome and then
they have to put together that full
narrative where they're including text
and math and code and visualization in
order to communicate some scientific
topic so this student did I think a
really great job of looking at if you
have a fluid running through a tube and
you come and squeeze the tube then what
happens to the fluid and if you put
blood rather than water into this tube
what happens so as you stop squeezing
the tube it relaxes into this default
meniscus and as you squeeze the tube it
starts to do some interesting things
because it's a viscous non-newtonian
fluid so this is the velocity
distribution
the front edge of the fluid as it flows
through so this is a student this is
week six of their first coding class and
they have gotten really interested in
microfluidics and chose to do an
independent research project already and
they're producing these great
visualizations by grabbing textbook
images and demonstration code and
merging the two so that's notebooks as a
structured place to help students learn
in computational science and I have four
minutes wait do I have four minutes
until I need to let everyone leave the
room or four minutes until questions oh
okay you guys don't get to hear about
the cool stuff all right I mean I guess
so all right I'll do a super brief one
in in this online course we are doing a
2x2 factorial design of trying to figure
out if you add visual widgets non visual
widgets coding or non-coding into a
class into a standard physics class do
you affect physics comprehension from
the beginning to the end or spatial
reasoning or coding ability so there's
these different aspects of things that
you could in fact improve by introducing
coding so we cohort them into five
groups where one just gets a standard
problem that they're going to do by
pencil and paper one gets that problem
plus a visual widget and some coding
exercise one gets a non visual widget
and some coding so let me show you
quickly the development of those things
so this is my other car in a bank turn
so this is the original question it was
a very standard looking physics textbook
question my problem statement is very
similar but I've added some fun color
and there's actually a story every week
Mary is this character who's become a
stunt driver and hey it was a racecar
driver and a stunt woman and a juggler
at a circus so she's kind of out there
engaging in the world so
cheering Marianas she goes around a
banks turn and so everyone gets to see
that picture one of the or two of the
groups get to see an interactive version
of that where they can come and make
Mary a very daring racecar driver and
then look at what happens as they rotate
their coordinate system and maybe they
want to consider working in this
coordinate system rather than the other
one because now there's only one vector
that's pointing not in the direction of
the origin area of the original
principal axes that's the word yes thank
you there's a physics II thing for this
the very lame non-visual widget is kind
of a calculator but these things
definitely exist and we want to see if
they actually have an impact so we give
one of two of the group's at non-visual
widget and then one of the group's gets
some code and they're told hey look you
can do rotation matrices and figure out
projections of vectors and hopefully
that helps them solve it and then
another group in order to standardize
time on tasks we give them a list of
questions just hope that they reflect
upon them in order to use a bit of time
like what happens if you you know
increase the bank or what if there's no
friction and things like that so that's
our experiment you'll have to come back
next year and I'll show actual numerical
results of the analysis we have 40
students in each one of the conditions
so I'm pretty excited we have sufficient
data that we'll be able to tell you if
there's an actual impact on any of these
interventions inside of standard physics
class okay all right thank you
[Applause]